begin with character end with character
find the story in between
start with that great premise what if
this happened
and then you ask yourself okay now who
would be the most interesting character
to put into that dilemma
should a writer start with character or
plot you know i sometimes say that there
are two kinds of writers the ones that
start with character the one that
is start with plot i think both are
valid ways
um i think however and
if someone starts with character i
wouldn't tell them that they're wrong
and that they shouldn't i think if you
start with plot
it's a little easier to to break story
and to work with story um so like the
example i was saying with groundhog day
you know if you start with
the premise is far more interesting than
the character
what if somebody woke up and it was the
same day
a second time that's a great premise
right
i want to start with that then ask
myself well who would be the most
interesting character
to put in that what if it was somebody
who's naive
that that probably wouldn't work ah what
if somebody was a jerk ah
now and that helps me build the plot and
the character
right so for me it works much more
naturally
and it's much more easy to work with
story
to start that way that said i know a lot
of people
start with character they love to
explore character that's you know
and for a variety of reasons sometimes
they came from an acting background
uh and and that's part of acting
training sometimes they'd like to get
inside a character's head
maybe they're doing a bio a biographical
figure and then you kind of
have to in a way you are starting with
the character and but you then need to
decide
what plot moments do i want to use
to help show this character's change and
what plot moments
am i going to leave out but then you
kind of necessarily are starting with
character
um but generally speaking if i had to
pick the two
of the two i would say plot is the most
easy to manipulate
manipulate and to build story around
um and to make sure you're you're
creating a satisfying story
start with that great premise what if
this happened
and then you ask yourself okay now who
would be the most interesting character
to put into that dilemma
begin with character end with character
find the story
in between i don't care what paradigm
people have in terms of story structure
how you get there is critical and so you
start with your characters that's
my take you know again there's not one
right way to do this
i'm just saying that this i think is a
is a smart way to go about it because
the characters it's their story
if we're writing a story we are assuming
that in some magical mystical way
that story universe exists those
characters exist
and if it's their story they know it
better than we do
and so character development is about
getting curious it's about asking
questions it's about spending
time with the characters and so the
typical
things that we see like biographies and
questionnaires
those are great i call those indirect
engagement exercises because you're
reflecting on the character thinking
about the character
as opposed to direct engagement
exercises so for example
what if i have a character in mind i'm
going to imagine i'm a psychiatrist
this character is my patient and if
they're reticent to talk to me i can
even go one step further
they have been court appointed to appear
with me as a psychiatrist
and they have to answer my questions if
they don't they will
stay stuck in the situation until they
do so you just create a situation in
which
like i was saying earlier you just ask
questions you get curious
when i was that's a lesson i learned
when i was an air force brat you just
ask people questions you get them
talking
and so you just you type you just let it
go you can even do something
um it's a little bit spiritual i suppose
you'd say in a way
where you're gonna do um either a
monologue or a stream of consciousness
with a character
it's sort of like a vulcan mind meld
even like star trek where you get a
character in your mind
and you do some deep breathing you get
yourself
so you're transitioning out of the busy
world and you're going to be here now
with this character and you set a timer
for like 15 minutes
and you put your fingers on the keyboard
or pin on paper
and you close your eyes and you just
type and you just type
and you know your mind will go oh i got
to get groceries or the cat whatever
just let that go you don't get attached
to it you just keep coming back to this
character
and you get done with this and so you've
got all these words that you've
typed out some of them are like dialogue
like a monologue and some of them are
just like
stream of consciousness 80 of it may
seem like gobbledygook to you
maybe 90 but 20 or 10
there's something really interesting
that popped out there
and that's getting in touch with the
characters
at a subconscious level and
they start to talk to you i've seen this
happen time and time again i created a
prep class 10 years ago that i teach
online
six week workshop taking a story from
concept to outline
and the first four weeks are all
character development
the second week is brainstorming that's
all they do is brainstorm
and i've had hundreds of people tell me
that was the most eye-opening experience
for them was doing that type of work
again the characters exist
we act on that belief and we reach out
to them
and get them talking to us so
the character development that's those
are some great examples for character
development what can happen out of that
is
if you identify a protagonist in
particular their state of disunity
where they are disconnected from their
authentic nature
and that can inform if you know what the
disunity state is
that can inform where the unity state is
and so now
they're not going to just jump there
then you're going to say okay so
these plot elements and the characters
with whom they intersect
they're going to deconstruct their old
ways of being because
they don't work out here in the new
world but in the process of that
they're going to uncover their need
their needs going to start to emerge
this is very union
jung talks about he says when an inner
situation is not made conscious and he's
talking about like conflict
inner conflict it happens outside
as fate now i don't know if that's real
and
you know in the real world but that's
the protagonist story
the protagonist starts off in a state of
disunity and
what happens in the plot is informed by
that there's a synergy between it it's
not just these random events
it's like these characters that they
intersect with and the events that they
go through
that's going to provide the basis of
their transformation
and so they're disunity that gets
deconstructed well now this stuff starts
to come out into the light of
consciousness
their need and then they move into
reconstruction now they're moving into
their new
mode of being and eventually toward
unity
so you can take that raw material that
you get with your
with your characters and see how that
starts to shape
the nature of the plot the story
structure and it's not just plugging
this in
you know this has to happen on page 25
the break into act 2.
no you're doing it through a much more
organic fashion with your characters and
letting them inform you what
what the structure will be and the final
value of that
is that you're writing multi-layered
richly textured characters
who actors want to play so character
development to me is like
everything it's absolutely critical
for me plot and the analysis of plot
can be a real
source of people getting stuck in their
writing because they feel that they need
to have a plot that works before they
write
now if you just write without a plot you
can also end up down a dark hole of
loose ends that you know lead nowhere
and just write for the rest of your life
without having a structure but
i find plot and the analysis of plot
um a good place to be once you've
written something but for me plot
arises out of characters in a space
doing something and that creates the
plot
the characters themselves are almost uh
it's like this whole separation of
character and plot
is is not actually real when you're
either creating it or watching it
characters and plot are intrinsically
linked um
we separate them in order to analyze and
maybe in the rewrite write our stories
better
but i do find that so if you just focus
on plot and drop the characters
um it can result in stories that are
feel a bit empty um and it can result in
stories that everyone's written before
what i find really funny about these
books on plot and some really good books
are written on plot and i point to them
in my book i don't talk about plot at
all in my book
what i find really funny about books on
plot is they'll say
these seven beats need to be in a story
they don't have to be there in that
order they don't all have to be there
and i'm like what do you mean they don't
have to be there in that order they
don't all that have to be there this is
kind of it's like a weird i don't know
if you read closely but they've all got
this disclaimer of like you know they
don't have to be in that order and they
don't have to necessarily all be there
and i'm like well what are you really
trying to say so i'm
slightly suspicious of generating new
idea writing from plot first
i think it can be really useful in the
rewrite it's definitely really useful in
the story edit
i use it all the time when i'm trying to
help writers strengthen
strengthen their stories but actually
the
best build on plot that i've ever heard
the best quote on plot
and it's not even about plot it's from
that book on filmmaking that i mentioned
earlier by alexander mckendrick he says
something like the only thing you need
to know
what's happening now in your story
should not be as
exciting or interesting as what may or
may not happen
later it's really simple what's
happening now
shouldn't be as interesting or exciting
as what may or may not happen later so
something's happening later
and it's drawing the story forward and
it's that thing that's happening later
that you need to put in your plot
somewhere so we need to know
that something's going to happen in the
you know you need to set it up so that
something's going to pay off
and that'll drive the story forward and
that'll keep people watching but i like
that because it's kind of an escapist
you know it's not really about plot but
it's kind of linked to
structure in some way so yeah i
i'm not anti-plot but um as a matter of
fact i'm pro-plot when it comes to
analysis of the story and trying to make
it stronger
because i do believe you have to take a
sledgehammer to your story once you've
written it
and hit it and if it breaks something's
wrong with the structure
and so you need to like make it work
character is story as i said before what
is a character other than what she does
and what she says
okay i have a friend um who uh is a tv
writer and he has a partner a writing
partner that collaborate
and so he told me that somebody said to
them oh you guys work to get so
like you do the character and he does
the story
as if you could do that separately uh
characters don't exist outside of
of stories um they exist only inside of
stories again they are what they like
hamlet they are what they do and what
they say so you can't
when people talk about a
character-driven
movie they just mean a good movie let me
just
point out to you how many movies
and plays and great classics are just
the name of the protagonist of the main
character for example
hamlet king lear macbeth
romeo juliet um
julius caesar that's just how they go
back to the greeks medea
oedipus
look at the great movies uh the
godfather
citizen kane um it's not always
that way but more often than not it is
the name of the character
that is also the name of the movie the
name of the protagonist and i only
mention it in this context because i'm
trying to indicate to you that
you can't separate story and character
which is more important it's like asking
somebody what's more important to you
your heart or your lungs sometimes in
the law they refer to
separately to plot and something they
call sequence of events
but to me plot and sequence is the
sequence of events
is the story plot sequence of event
story
uh visa synonyms at least in in lay
terms you know just just and it's the
most important thing and
and the hardest and most difficult the
most elusive thing to achieve is a good
story
i could paint for you a word picture of
a wacky crazy kind of a
character and there's there are
workshops that actually do this
um you just invent characters
and you talk about what kind of a tree
she would be if she were a tree
and what kind of candy bar she would eat
if she ate a candy bar
and all of these and people feel all
kind of creative they create these
things but
it's nonsense i think it's actually
anti-useful
because it suggests that characters
exist outside of stories
what i want to hear is when students
pitch
their stories in my classes they're
orally telling the story to me and the
eight writers around the table including
themselves
what i want to hear is what do we see
and what do we hear i don't want to hear
that um
harry enters he's had a job years ago
when he worked
he never got along with his mother uh
he's the kind of guy who does it but
please just tell me i mean how is the
audience
sitting in the movie theater going to
get that they're going to get that from
what they see and what they hear
nobody's going to be sitting next to
them whispering in their ear let me tell
you about this part that's coming up
what i was trying to do here
um so that's what i want to hear in the
class from the writers we see this we
hear that
and that's what readers for agents and
for production companies
want to see on the page we see this we
hear that that's
all there is and everything else
has to come out of that so finally an
answer to your question
yeah i knew we'd get there eventually i
told you this this was four places
is um yeah if you gave us a premise we
would
eagerly take a shot at it knowing that
where we started would not be the place
where it ended
and it was particularly fascinating in
the book
when we had teams working where they
would just
one would start riffing and the other
would just pick it up and then the other
would go backward
and they'd just go back and forth right
or they would
they would change the sex they'd say we
don't know anything about
mothers and daughters but fathers and
sons we know a lot about so let's
let's make it a father and son or in one
case my favorite interview they
the grandparents are just lightly
mentioned in
in in the premise and lou lou uh
schneider made it a story more about the
grandparents and the mother and then the
daughter the daughter kind of got lost
in it
so you know that's the other thing is
i think that the book does something
that
i've never seen a book do before it
replicates
not because of us because of the writers
it replicates what a writer's room would
be like because a writer's room
you come in you you might have the arc
of the season
you might have those things but you need
episodes along that line
and they'll pitch an idea and somebody
go that's not going to work or we did
that three years ago
or blah blah blah whatever it is but
ideas come in the room and as peter said
they are not the same at the end as when
they start now i'm going to take
us back to your questions sure um
when jeffrey and i were starting we
we took a slightly academic view one day
and said
what's your prediction about the
approach they're going to take
are they going to go more for story are
they going to go more for character
and we found out the answer is neither
they went for conflict and
so if you were to give us a premise to
develop the very first step we would
take is
okay whatever the premise is where do we
get conflict out of it
okay if there are two characters
involved how can we make them butt heads
to do something
because everything would come out of
that again
there's not one right way to do this i'm
just saying that this
i think is a is a smart way to go about
it
because the characters it's their story
you know i sometimes say that there are
two kinds of writers
the ones that start with character the
one that is start with plot i think both
are valid ways